[Musique]
ugin Mar
Ross j'en a Mar
dépêche-toi j'ai 100000 choses à faire
tu me prends tout mon temps reprends-le
et m'attends tu serais bien embêté vive
la
liberté dé marque ce que tu crois on n
plus au moyen âge je veux vivre ma vie
mais pas au ralenti je fais ce que je
veux si tu veux mais fais-le c'est pas
facile mais c'est de
timporte la vie tranquille c'est pas
pour
demain c'est
dramatique
mais c'est de ta
fa quand on
t'explique tu ne comprends
rien je ne suis pas une poupée au grand
yeux de
forceine moi je ris moi je pleure tu
n'as rien dans le cœur enthousiasme et
amour que j'attends nuit et jours j'en
ai marre de
gaspiller mon temps avec les problèmes
d'une viille compliquée d'une fille
humiliée moi j'ai besoin d'une femme
j'ai besoin de mon âme c'est pas
facile mais c'est de ta
faute la vie de famille c'est pas pour
demain c'est
dramatique mais c'est le
TA
quand on
t'explique tu ne comprends
rien j'en ai marre
dépêche-toi on perd son temps à se
battre appille-toi je t'attend j'en ai
plus pour longtemps avant tout sois
jolie après tout tu es gentil finalement
tu es jolie gentil oui je dis
dis allez
bon